welcome to the program a battle is
underway in the occupied West Bank after
Israeli forces raided the Janine refugee
camp
[Music]
a large number of security officers
entered from different directions in the
early hours of Thursday morning the
health Ministry says at least eight
Palestinians are dead joining us on the
phone now is Ahmed Maha who's making his
way to Janine hello there Ahmed it seems
there have been daily raids in Janine
for the past two weeks what more can you
tell us about today's incident
yeah today the Israeli forces is torment
the refugee camp engine in one of the
cities and the occupied West Bank at
seven uh local time which is five GMP
and uh the it is part of an intense
fight campaign by the Israeli forces
against uh what they call militants uh
Palestinian factions in the refugee camp
and in Janine over the past two to four
weeks Israel has intensified its
campaign against the Palestinian
factions there since the start of the
year uh at least 28 people were killed
and including five children and in
today's rate this is the highest death
toll in at least four or five months we
are talking now about five Palestinians
killed
16104 critically inequate condition and
this is going on and despite the fact
that the Palestinian Authority is
technically governing Janine other towns
and they occupied with bank but the
Palestinians are upset and frustrated
that this is going on day and night and
Non-Stop and also it coincides with the
inauguration of the new Israeli
government which includes senior
ministers from the far right and these
ministers like the national security
minister vows and bridges day in day out
that there will be another decisive war
against the Palestinian factions like
Hamas the Islamic and he said two days
ago just two days ago that this war is
imminent
Ahmed we're hearing reports of that
death toll continues to rise how is this
violence impacting the people that in
Janine do you think
well I mean the genuine residence
are staying up late waiting for the next
military weeks in the city they're
saying they are exhausted they start to
think that when will it or ask this
question when will it be my turn when
will it be my son or another family
member and this increases the cycle of
frustration because Israel as they say
is resulting to the same old policy
which is the heavy-handed policy and
um they are just frustrated you know
they fear that they can't go to work or
when they go to work and suddenly come
come upon Israeli soldiers and the
streets and they could shoot me oh them
as they say so it's a cycle of
frustration and
um and they just exhausted
I bet they are all right thank you very
much for breaking it all down for us and
make sure you get in touch once you
arrive at the scene Ahmed Maher for us
on the phone Let's cross to West
Jerusalem now where Imran Khan is
standing by for us Imran put this into
context why are these raids happening on
such a regular basis
something
well to put it very clearly and very
simply the Israelis are after wanted
terrorists their words uh they say the
Janine refugee camp and other towns in
the occupied West Bank particularly in
the north are harboring wanted
terrorists so these operations have been
going on uh for a very long time in the
last couple of weeks they have
intensified but they've been going on
for the last 12 months now this
particular operation we're hearing uh
Israeli media quote Israeli intelligence
sources saying that they went in for
this particular operation to thwart a
major and immediate terrorist attack now
we can't confirm that but that's the
language that we see constantly being
used by the Israelis the Israelis say
the Palestinian resistance Fighters that
are in Janine refugee camp are wanted
terrorists and they're going to go in
heavy-handed they're going to go in with
special forces with the backing of the
Israeli Army in some cases to get those
terrorists out oftentimes what happens
though is you know civilians are caught
in the middle of this as we've seen over
the last few weeks now that hasn't
dampened uh the Israeli further to try
and go into Janine refugee camp indeed
it's actually just getting stronger this
right-wing government are you my
colleague actually mentioned the the
far-right government there that's right
one government is actually in no mood to
back down from Janine refugee camp it
wants to push further wants to go deeper
into uh the Palestinian refugee camps to
root out what they like I say called
terrorists now the more that that
happens the more that that pushes
Palestinians for example to try and join
up to defend themselves so it is a cycle
of violence that continues but the
Israelis are absolutely clear there are
wanted terrorists within uh Janine
refugee camp if the media reports are to
be believed then there was a major and
immediate threat of a terror attack this
is all the Israeli terminology I'm using
by the way so
there is no kind of will to back down
from the Israelis in fact escalation is
a word that we're hearing more and more
item who's the national security
minister says that there will be a uh
escalation there will be a a war with
Gaza at some point or on Gaza uh is a
more accurate term at some point in the
future so the Israelis uh aren't going
to look at this and see eight
Palestinians Dead uh as something that
they need to back away from it's likely
that these raids are going to become
ever more frequent all right thank you
very much for the update Imran and just
some word from our news desk the
Palestinian Ministry of Health says nine
Palestinians have now been killed in
Janine including an elderly woman thank
you very much Imran Khan